Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron cousins from Ring of Fire,
sitting in for David today. And if you want even
more from me, you can subscribe to my YouTube
channels, YouTube.com slash the Ring of Fire
and YouTube.com slash fair and balanced. And I
also host the Ring of Fire podcast every week.
You can catch that on R.A.F. podcast dot com.
Fox News, as I'm sure everybody is aware, has a
defamation trial coming up and so far it is not
looking good for the right wing network. Late
last week it was announced that they privately
settled a defamation claim brought against
them by Venezuelan businessman Majid Kaleel
and Kalil had been accused on Lou Dobbs program by
none other than Sidney Powell herself of running a
scheme in Venezuela. He helped allegedly get Hugo
Chavez elected, working with those Dominion voting
machines and all that other stuff. And none of it
was true. It was, in fact, a complete fabrication.
So Khaleel sued for defamation, and last week,
Fox News settled. Now, that lawsuit, of course,
is not necessarily. As intense as the Dominion
voting Systems defamation suit and of course,
the other defamation suit filed against Fox News
by Smartmatic. However, some of the claims with
that particular lawsuit that Fox has now settled
are also brought up in Dominion's lawsuit. So
it's a big deal, especially now. Dominion
can go to court and be like, look, jury,
they just settled a lawsuit making the same
claims that we're listing here. So that's
kind of them admitting that, yeah, it was bad
and we'll give you money for it. So I know Fox
News wants their legal problems to go away. But at
this stage in the game, if you're going to settle,
you probably need to go ahead and settle all of
them. That's not a good look for the network.
And in a really, really surprising move last
week, Fox News also filed a letter with the court,
letting them know that they are going to be
offering up certain hosts to testify at the trial.
Those hosts include Laura Ingraham, Sean HANNITY
and Tucker Carlson. The three people whose text
messages have been revealed in court filings
where they talk about how they know what they're
saying is not true. They talk about firing other
people from the networks, producers, hosts for
telling the truth. I don't know why Fox News
would say, hey, you want to talk to these guys
under oath on the stand in front of a jury? Go for
it. That seems like a really, really dumb move.
I understand in the criminal justice
system, even in the civil justice system,
which is what this is, sometimes you
want the defendant to take the stand
because they may be able to offer pieces of
evidence or information that might otherwise
not be known. Right. They have their firsthand
accounts. They may be able to convince a jury
with their words that they didn't do whatever
it is they're accused of doing. But in the case
of Fox News, HANNITY, Ingram, Carlson and the
other hosts that they have offered up. We have
your text messages, we have your emails. There
is nothing you can say to justify that material.
That is already public knowledge. And that, of
course, will be brought up in the trial. It will
be blown up and shown on big TVs screens for the
jury to see. Word for word what these people said.
All this does. And again, I'm still shocked my
mind is blown that Fox News is stupid enough
to offer these idiots up on the stand. All it's
going to do is allow the plaintiffs lawyers to
walk up there, point to these statements from
somebody like Tucker Carlson and say, Tucker,
what does this mean? You sent this, right? Yes, I
sent it. Did you mean it? Well, yes, I meant it.
So explain to the jury what this means. That
is not going to end well for Fox, like 100%.
Not going to go their way. And speaking of other
things, not going Fox News way, they also recently
tried to prevent Rupert Murdoch from having to
testify at the trial. They argued in front of the
judge that said, listen, Judge Rupert Murdoch, he
already sat for hours and hours in the deposition.
It's on video that gets shown during the trial,
too. So he doesn't he doesn't need to come
testify. Plus, he's old. Traveling is hard for
him. And the judge actually ruled against that,
saying, listen, Rupert Murdoch's been traveling
all over the world recently and now suddenly
he's too old to come to Delaware to testify. No,
I don't buy it. I'm not going to go along with it.
Also last week with this lawsuit, Fox News went
to court and asked the judge to bar certain topics
from being discussed at the trial. One of those
topics was the Capitol riot. Fox's lawyer said,
Hey, Judge, we don't want any discussion during
this trial of the Capitol riot. No mention of the
Capitol riot. January six basically doesn't exist
in terms of this trial. Oh, and also, we want
you to ban any mention of the death threats that
Dominion Voting Systems employees have received.
Now, to a degree, I understand that the Capitol
riot really doesn't have anything to do with the
defamation of dominion. Okay. Those two are not
linked. So I get why you should say we shouldn't
talk about it. I just also find it weird that
you specifically want to bar it makes me think
you got something else up your sleeve. But
the death threats against Dominion employees,
that's literally relevant to the case. That is, a
lot of what the case hinges on is the harassment
that these workers suffered because of your
lies. Not to mention, as Dominion pointed out,
in a counter filing. People don't want to come
to work for us because they're afraid they're
going to get killed because of the lies
that you've spread about our network. So,
yeah, that hurts our business, which falls
under the category of a defamation claim.
Foxes in trouble. Foxes in big trouble. Are
they in financial trouble? Not really. It's
going to hurt them. Yeah, because they're going
to end up paying out a lot of money. Probably
not the total 4 billion that the two lawsuits
combined are seeking. But they're going to pay
out hundreds of millions of dollars. Like I think
that much. It's pretty much a given at this point.
But the credibility that the network is suffering,
that's going to be almost impossible to overcome.
And what I mean by that is they're not going to
lose the audience they already have. Those people
are Fox News viewers. They still believe Fox did
nothing wrong. Those people aren't going anywhere.
What they're going to have trouble with is when
their very old audience dies off. There's not an
audience coming up behind to replace them. That's
the credibility problem. So in the short term,
Fox will be fine. Couple of years down the road,
however, they're going to be in serious trouble